touche pas mon
poste euh on reviendra bien entendu sur
sur sur Sébastien cé qui a porté plainte
la plaignante aussi le groupe Energie a
réagi aujourd'hui également on va on va
refaire un gros point sur cette affaire
et euh on a on agile encore des des
nouvelles des nouveaux éléments voilà
exactement et ça bouge encore ça bouge
encore euh tout àtis merci d'être là euh
on va revenir sur votre vidéo vous allez
répondre parce que tout le monde se
demande voilà tout le monde a donné son
son avis ici voilà donc vous avez donné
le le sein à votre neveu puis que c'est
le fils de votre sœur n n ex vois votre
niè voilà et donc ça a fait un buzz
incroyable voilà donc voilà donc qui est
choqué ce qu'on vous a demandé choqué
pas choqué on vous demande également
chez vous à 20h41 on en direct Diane moi
je suis un peu choquée mais en fait dans
l'absolu ça m'aurait pas dérangé s' y
avait eu un message àc ouais c'est ça
c'estàdire que si vous aviez dit dedans
bah que c'était justement parce que vous
voulez allter la merde d'allaitement et
cetera pourquoi pas c'est un vrai
message et ça peut être intéressant
justement pour les gens qui ne s'y
connaissent pas là juste comme ça j'ai
l'impression qu'effectivement c'est un
appel au buzz parce que on se doute
qu'il y a pas de lait là tout de suite
ça a pas été travaillé avant si vous
dites en plus que le bébé il est mort
ENF il est né il y a pas longtemps je
suis un peu surprise de du snap juste
pris comme ça parceil est vraiment été
posté comme ça ça surprendque symbolique
mais symbolique mais sans message moi et
ma sœur la mère de l'enfant d'ailleurs
ou mais sans message que là par montrer
ça il y a pas grand chose s y avait
vraiment moi j'aurais V dans la story
justement j'avais fait une story j'ai
pas fait que ce snap j'avais fait toute
une story et j'ai fait au moins 50 snap
puis j'ai fait cette vidéo de 3 secondes
je pensais pas qu'elle allait faire
autant de buzz mais pour moi c'était pas
un truc de de malade de faire ça alors
vous allez répondre dans un instant à
tout le monde aussi tout à Ti Gill vous
avez changé d'avis vous oui oui j'ai
entendu geréraldine et c'est
inacceptable de son côté donc voilà
bravo tout bravo alors Raymon toi tu es
choqué toi ouis je suis choqué parce que
c'est faire du buzz avec le petit ça
sert à rien sa sœur elle peut allaitter
si sa sœur elle pouvait pas allaiter
mais sa sœur elle peut allaiter là c'est
juste pour pour se montrer sur Instagram
pour faire bien elle est jeune moi moi
je suis pas dans le délire des
influenceurs ni des influenceuses je
trouve ça je trouve ça dommage il y a
même pas de lait aur du lait
[Rires]
encore magnifque il a même pas de
la du lait pour avoir du lait faut
commencer
comm hab
hab une merre ta sœur elle a du lait
elle fera du lait tu as rien à [__]
làdedans mais mais fais un enfant c'est
pas ton enfant continue à faire tes stor
coucou les loulou laisse la maternité
laisse la maternité laisse tomber la
maternité
auors il est là le petit le petit
s'acharne il est là tté il y a rien qui
sort laisse tranquille laisseto
tranquille le petit il va grandir
tranquillement laissezle en dehors de
vos conneries là plus ouais en plus il y
a un truc obsè c'estd que d'abord moi je
trouve que un nouveau né c'est pas pas
un
gadget sex car ouais en fait côé le
nouveau en fait tu tu
l'utilisutilise en vous l'utilisez pour
le mettre sur votre nichon qui est
par et en plus vous sexualisez vous
sexualisez
l'allaitement j'ai écris oh j'aime trop
ça j'écris quoi il rien arrêtez arrêtez
il y a que Gill Verdez et Jean-Michel
mer qui sont assez nig pour tomber
dans mais vous banalisez le fait de
donner le sein quand on est la sœur de
quelqu'un ça veut dire quoi c'est où la
limite après c'est la mère la tante la
grand-mère c'est
pas même s elle m'autorise à le faire
pour sa fille qui vient elle me dit oui
la fille elle me dit oui toute la
famille est là je fais mon petit de 3
secondes mais je cherche le buz oui
faisle il a pas de lait mais faisle
laisse le tter dans le vide il faut bien
commencer pour avoir du
la c'est vrai c'est pas sa man elle va
pas venir tous les jours pour le faire
pourquoi pas sa man demain vous y allez
demain je crois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle y va demain elle y vaoui mais
l'allement en tant que tel c'est beau
comme image on l'a désacralisé on a
arrêté justement d'avir ce tabou là le
problème c'est que justement en faisant
ça moi je vois pas en quoi sur la vidéo
j'ai sexualisé quelque chose pas dit
sexualisé M il a
pas plus est de PE faire deèrei mais que
c'est pas ton enfant tu ne peux pas
donner de lait je vois pas le message
vous alleziter ou pas finalement alors
qu'est-ce
déci aujourd'hui vous êtes pass à
l'hôpital pour qu'
vous vous AZ de là déjà ou y aller
demain
appar CZ à ce qu'on dit là donc fait tu
viens dire tu viens dire c'est intime
c'est comme de lein c'est
intime ça veut
direent pas
snappervez répondre à tout le monde vous
diriez quoi comment si vous deviez
répondre à tout le mondez qu j'imais
qu'on appelle ma sœur parce que ma sur
qui est la mère de l'enfant elle
aimerait parler d'accord V que c'est son
enfant concerné bien sûr d'accord et
sinon qu'est-ce que vous voulilez dire
parce qu'on va on est en train d'appeler
votre sœur elle va intervenir d'accord
euh j'aimerais dire que j'ai eu l'accord
de ma sœurah oui queil y en a chez
certaines personnes c'est culturel que
c'est symbolique que la sœur ou que la
mère de la personne qui vient
d'accoucher donne l'enfant donne le sein
à l'enfant qui vient de naître c'est pas
du tout sexuel c'est pas du tout pervers
je cherchis pas le buzz j'ai fait 70000
snap le jour même où la magè est né mais
c'est ça qu'on a retenu elle s'appelle
commentur Cupidon Leana Leana Leana LAN
euh je crois non mais il y a sa sœur oui
bonsoir tu as dit quoi bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir ça euh alors ça va bien
oui ça va et vous alors dites-nous ce
que vous vouliez direah félicitations
déjà bah félicitations déjà
félicitations déjà hein oui
félicitations pour moi bravo bravo bravo
alors et et euh allô oui oui j'ai
accouché il y a moins de 48h et mon
enfan est déjà dans une SA Twitter je
comprends pas trop euh en sachant que
j'ai autorisé ma sœur euh à alléé mon
enfant donc je vois pas en quoi c'est un
problème c'est mon enfant d'accord donc
vous voilà donc c'est vous lui avez
donné l'autorisation vous voilà donc il
y a vous voyez pas le problème en fait
c'est ça c'est ça voilà donc VO voilà
donc elle dit je comprends pas que mon
enfant il soit déjà dans une sauce sur
Twitter ou sa sœur elle est elle est à
fond dans les réseaux sociaux elle sa
sur F son enfant bah vous dites que vous
comprenez pas que votre enfant il soit
déjà dans la SA sur Twitter en MOS de
48h mais votre votre sœur elle est
connue c'est une influenceuse pourquoi
vous la laissez vous filmez votre bébé
mais alors attendez attendez com dans
écoutez je vois pas en quoi laêement
c'est quelque chose do sexualisé en fait
moi j'ai rien sexualisé moi j'ai pas
sexualisé je répond juste à votre
question vous dites que mon mon enfant
est déjà dans la SAU c'est normal
qu'avec votre sœur il va être dans la
sace écoutez écoutez vous sexualisez ça
parce que non j'ai rien sexualisé moi je
je sexualise pas un enfant avec le sein
d'une dame qui lui donne Leens qui
sexualis ça moi je seualise Ren tout je
fais ça pour les vues parce que c'est
mes seinsce que c'est
moi j'ai parlé ah c'est ici le vieux con
entendu Jean-Michel Jean-Michel quand
vous entendez ça vous dites quoi vous ah
non mais moi je trouve ça incroyable di
excuse-moi tu dis c'est quoi le message
quand tu fais Miss Univers c'est quoi le
message aux extraterrestres je suis
célibataire c'est quoi il y a pas de
messageis là tu confonds tout non mais
encore une fois l'allatement moi ça me
choque pas je trouve ça beau il faut le
montrer faut il faut justement rendre l'
sexuel et cetera c'est le fait que tu le
poes sans rien quoi là c'est juste posté
comme ça donc on comprend pas est mais
je comme ça je NPP ma nourriture des
fois bah il y a pas de message
rien quandme y a une naissance qui en
arrivé et C les
gens choqu les gens j'en a fait plein
d'autres j'ai pas eu que ça j'ai écrit
des longs textes
même ça vous choque en fait moi je
trouve ça m'aurait pas dérangé si vous
ne l'aviez pas publié et je trouve ça
obsène de le publier aurait pas été là
Onura pas fait le sujet qu'est-ce que tu
es
con par fait dans une immense hypocrisie
depuis tout à l'heure la réalité c'est
que ça vous choque uniquement parce que
c'est diffusé donc je suis pas con mon
cher verdz parce que ça en soi ça me
choque pas du tout puisque ma première
réaction a été de dire moi en fait je
m'en fiche parce que il y a il y a il y
a il y a 150 ans il y avait des
orphelinas il y avait des nourrices qui
le faisaient et qui le et c'était pas
comme l'expliqué tout à l'heure
Jean-Michel c'était la cousine c'était
des membres de la famille donc en soi
c'est pas quelque chose qui me choque
après je sais pas s'il faut avoir un
enfant pour pouvoir le
faire
au fait que les
goui on a une
auditrice tu nous appelles pour les je
je de 1000
€ voulez dire quelque chose oui oui
oui c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire
quoi
merci ok vous vouz raccrocher vous avez
autre chose à [__] et je comprends
tout à fait merci en tout cas en gros
tout ce que je vis dire c'est que mon
enfant c'est pas un joue y a pas besoin
de
faire
putainad ou oui on est toujours là c'est
contradictoire de faire Dr pour un tton
ok
ok tut mer mais c'est bon on va
parler un téton
d'accord merci je
tut
[Applaudissements]
mer on va laisser on va laisser touttis
voilà terminer clôturer ce ce ce débat
combi important bah oui mais c'est vrai
bah ouiah oui oui c'est important oui
c'est important oui tout F en vrai oui
tout as que j'ai laaccord de la mère
c'est OK donner le sein c'est pas sexuel
c'est pas pervers c'est pas pour les
vues c'est pas pour MIM c'est pas unû
bien sûr il y a rien de bizarre c'est
familial c'est symbolique c'est culturel
chez nous et c'est tout c'est tout c'est
vrai que c'est très ménagère ouais non
mais c'est vrai donc ça va vous allez
refaire oui quand bah ça fa je sais pas
quand
oui c'est parce que c'est par que par
rapport à ce qu'on a dit c'est une
logique
C prod partout en France et en Europe ce
pens télpectateur tout oui8% des gens
sont encore du mauvais côté répondez
tout on a dit que la terre était ronde
il y avait 99 % de des gens qui étaient
choqués sur terre de ma fautee ça
excuse-moi tu as d'autres
arguments merci qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous VZ nous dire que vous voudriez
nous dire en ha de la fin tout
tis tout il v la vie allez je suis
contente fr ma nièce voilà la vie voilà
comment s'appelle Leana mais tout le
monde s'appelle Leana non mais elle l'a
déjà dit tout à l'heure mais ah je
croyais que c'était votre sœur ah non
mais s c'est MAA je crois tout le monde
Sapp je pensais que sa sœur s'appelait
Lana aussi dis en fait appz vous app
Lana en vrai aussi moi non Jessie Jessie
d'accord on embrasse en tout cas votre
sœur et Lana merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous et bon c'est rien de grave
he non c'est rien de grave vous savez
pas si j'ai du lait ou pas alors moi je
ne veux pas le
savoir personnellement voilà moi je ne
veux pas savoir pas posé la question pr
je ne veux pas le savoir cétait une très
belle question avez-vous du lait on vous
la reposera certainement euh très
couramment merci donc voilà merci merci
en tout cas voilà et je rappelle que les
produits laitiers sont nos amis pour la
vi c'est c'est important merci merci t à
tous merci d'avoir été là
merci allez euh